hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from the Norway
chess classical tournament or the
classical Armageddon tournament as if
the classical remains in a draw then
they play a quick Armageddon game
because every round and it must have a
winner that's how they are playing it
and it's been I believe the the fourth
year that they are using this system I
could be wrong but I think it's four so
it's Fabiano caruana versus former World
classical Champion Magnus Carlsen and uh
he uh chooses a very a very special uh
opening for this game and that is the
French defense so let's see how this
plays out Fabi has the white pieces and
he opened with Ponte E4 uh Ponte E6
Magnus goes for the French defense d4d5
Knight to C3 and now nice to F6 and no
that is not the reason I chose this game
Pawn to E5 the steinits variation
against a magnus's classical setup
Knight f37 and of course Pawn to F4 we
have Pawn to C5 and Knight to F3 when
you're playing against the player of uh
caruana's caliber of course you can
expect the main line and the well even a
few surprises uh uh in the middle of the
main line Knight the C6 with Bishop to
E3 A6 and now Knights the E2 and this is
sort of the first surprise Fabi throws
at Magnus here the top moves are queen
to the 2.83 bishop to E2 and the Knights
the D2 which is kind of the fourth most
popular option uh and Magna shows that
this is not nothing new to him he knows
of course how to play this queen to B6
now puts more pressure on the center and
also on the B2 Pawn with Queen to C1 now
defending the B2 pawn and Bishop to E7
uh the D4 Pawn is sufficiently defended
so you don't need to worry about that we
have C3 and now Castles by by Magnus we
have won the G3 and pawn to F6 this is
uh how you play against them at this
setup that that Fabi has he has a very
strong central setup and you want to
play F6 and uh break through that so
Bishop to G2 C captures on D for Magnus
captures once C captures and queen to A5
with check and there is a game that was
played some 12 years ago between
pacovejo and Henry Danielson in the 18th
European uh Team Championship that was
won by by pacojo but in that game uh
Bishop taditu was played here we have
Knight back to C3 and it is now as of
move 14 that we have a completely new
game so Knights the B6 Magnus now ready
to throw that Knight to C4 and he
captures on F6 Bishop captures and pawn
to B3 now stopping Knight to C4 uh
Bishop to D7 and now just castles and
here of course you have to be
a little bit careful about that night or
the queen is the only piece that's
defending it so Rook the C8 uh preparing
to add more Firepower and that C file
and queen to D2 just getting the queen
out of that uh C file you don't want the
Rook x-raying the queen uh for too long
Knights the E2 of uh sorry Bishop D7
first and now Knights the E to offering
a queen trade uh five Magnus except we
have captures on the two Bishop captures
on D2 and now Rook to C7 getting ready
to double up on the C file Rook a to C1
and now Rook F to C8 and Fabi finds a
very interesting move in The Possession
because it's not easy to push anything
here Magnus has pretty much everything
covered except one thing and that is uh
the uh this diagonal basically he plays
F5 and now Magnus can't really capture
on uh F5 if he captures them Bishop to
F4 it traps The Rook on C8 so he needs
to deal with that he plays Bishop to A3
attacks five is rook and C1 and now Rook
C to E1 or you could uh capture on E6
first and then play Rook D1 uh he
decides to do it this way Rook C to E1
uh Bishop to B for offering a trade of
Bishops and now Fabi trades Bishop
captures on B4 Knight captures some B4
and now F captures an E6 with Bishop
captures and E6 and Knight to F4 Fabi
goes after the bishop on E6 and now
Bishop to F5 Magnus is even happy that
he uh traded his backwards E6 spawn now
they're they're they are both left with
an isolated d-pawn and it's a pretty
equally equal position so here Knight's
the E5 that is now a monster Knight so
you don't want to leave it there for too
long Pawn to G6 we have Pawn to G4
chasing away the bishop and the bishop
to E4 Bishop captures we have Pawn
captures and now uh Ponte A3 chasing
away the Knight if you're wondering uh
do you capture the pawn well you could
but then you also lose the A2 Pawn so
First Pawn to A3 Knight for to D5 uh now
asking are you ready to capture on e4
and Fabi is we have Rook captures on e4
and now Rook the C3 Magnus goes for the
pawns with this very active Rook we have
Knights to D7 uh and here Magnus has to
be very very careful there there are but
a few uh moves that Magnus could play
here in order not to get in trouble too
much like Rook to C1 is an option uh he
could go Rogue back to C7 he could play
Rook to d8 those are all the options
except to move that Magnus played he
played Rook capture some B3 and believe
it or not uh this move loses Magnus the
game it's not easy to spot why and this
is a classical game we are only at move
32 we haven't even discussed any lines
because most of it uh has all been
played before this is fairly uh fairly
uh irregular stuff but the magnets
already blunders here with Rook captures
on B3 so now feel free to pause the
video and win the game for Fabi while I
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding this
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show look at this
Knight captures on D5 and okay that's
probably one of the first moves that you
thought of Knight captures on D5 and now
Rook to E5 and remarkable as it is
there's no good way to defend the knight
uh the F6 square is covered this is
covered if you if you try to defend it
let's say Rook to B5 then you run into
Rook captures on D5 and after of course
uh Rook captures Knight to F6 check wins
even more material so there's really not
all that much you can do here if you go
Knights to E3 which is also very nice
then you just run into either Checkmate
or you lose more material for example
Knight to F6 check and now if you go to
G7 then Rook D7 check and it's all over
you either go to the f file and then
Rook captures an E3 followed by Knight
D5 Discovery capturing the Knight or you
go to H6 and then you just get
checkmated Rook H7 King to G5 and Ponte
H4 will be Checkmate if you go the F7
right away it's pretty much the same
thing you just capture on E3 and that's
it you're up a full piece through a
captress knight the D5 opens up a
discovery the king will move it doesn't
really matter where you're gonna capture
The Rook here now you're up a full night
of course completely winning so Magnus
tried Knight the C3 but it doesn't help
him all that much Fabi just played
Knight to F6 with check and believe it
or not it was in this position and move
35 that Magnus Carlsen resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
absolutely incredible stuff by Fabi
Magnus makes one little mistake and the
Fabi takes advantage of it okay Magnus
was a bit lower on time he had less than
10 minutes Fabi had like 20 minutes on
the clock but still uh very nicely done
it's not not in you know a small feat
taking down the former world champion
Magnus Carlsen in a classical game as he
is well pretty much almost the 100
rating points higher rated than pretty
much every other chess player in the
world you know except except those
special few now here you resign okay
maybe Magnus resigned a bit too early
here because you could still put a
little bit of you know defense but I
guess he just wasn't interested to give
you an example okay your choices are
basically King to G7 or King to F7 now
let's discuss what happens if King to G7
then you first play D5 you're gonna
Advance the pawn Rook to The Rook D7
check is coming there's really no way to
stop that and if Knight the B5 guarding
the D6 Square now you go Rook to E7 with
check King to f8 and now Rook uh if you
don't go to fade then you again get
checkmated so Rook capture some B7 can
be played and if Knight's the D4 now
you'll play Knight captures on H7 with
each other there are just too many
discoveries and you can't keep an eye on
all of them Knight to F6 checking back
to f8 now you can even trade real
captors Knight captures and pawn to D6
there's no way to stop the pawn uh King
to F7 doesn't really matter what you
play upon the D7 Rook to d8 Now Pawn to
G5 defends the Knight
and there is zero counter play here for
uh for black there are basically no
moves that you can make you can you know
horse around with your knight a little
bit uh the other idea after Knight to F6
check you can play King the F7 not King
to G7 uh but it's not much better
Knights the D7 check can be played King
will move and now Pawn to D5 again you
start advancing your Pawn uh black can
even trade off some material but that
will only favor white let's say We'll
capture some B1 I'd capture some B1 Pawn
to D6 is coming Ponte H6 now rooked the
E7 cutting off the king from advancing
uh further uh from the back rank even
Rook to C1 check let's take a rook to D1
sorry King to F2 now I've broke the D1
going after the pawn you just deliver a
nice check Knight to F6 check King to f8
Knight to H7 with checking the G8 Pawn
to D7 and that's it again not not a lot
to do here for black so there were a few
more moves of course Magnus could have
explored but he decided that okay he
knows that he's going to lose this he
just doesn't want to a little look at
this position as I'm pretty much sure
that he was disgusted with himself as he
usually is when he plays a bad game uh
so yeah there we have it Fabiano Corona
starting off the at the uh classical
portion of the Norway chess with a bang
definitely taking down the former World
classical champion and you can see that
okay that doesn't mean all that much but
S5 did much better than Magnus he got
fourth place in the blitz section uh and
Magnus got seven plays that means Fabi
will get an extra white in the
tournament so again that goes that can
go a long way uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it not a lot to
discuss in this game as it was you know
pretty clean on both sides Magnus just
made a terrible blunder and Fabi you
know honed in on it like like a hawk and
just uh obliterated Magnus uh so yeah
once again I really hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank Marcus
grebel Ubuntu Revolution reptiles
YouTube Michael Zacharias and David
esparian for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here and thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the classical
section of the Norway chess tournament
until it's been finishes uh thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day